my name is Robert oxytocin as I said you
can find me on most of things that
robbed
axelsson I'm a software developer by day
by profession I learned to code mainly
be a free code camp meetup we are at now
is for free code camp dot org and I also
organized my lips this meetup here and
also of IANA Go Go line meet up and view
jazz Vienna when I really love being
around the open-source and developer
geek community so I keep doing this
because it's ultimately fun if you want
to learn more about mine and Danielle's
journey to going from learn to code and
getting a first developer job you can go
to my website and there's a link to our
talk there okay so let's go straight
into it the first obstacle that you
might meet and to preface it these
obstacles are mainly based on my own
experience and talking to people
fellow coach students this is by no
means as of this talk an exhaustive list
so please feel free again in the
questions section to ask will leave room
for questions after the talk so when
you're dealing with time the time might
be an issue because I think starting out
it's easy to think that oh you know I'll
put like three weeks into this and I
really focus and maybe I'll learn a lot
and then you realize after three months
that oh god there's so much to learn so
there's different ways that time can hit
you in the face but I think there are
some things to keep in mind to not get
too overwhelmed or too impatient one
thing is to accept that learning takes
time yes it doesn't take too long to
learn the basics of programming that's
one thing that I struggle with on the
opposite of time was that I thought it
would take both the mind of a genius
you know was it called prodigy or a
really really long time and math skills
to lunch program but I kept having to
face that myth or misconception and I
gradually learned that no it's easier to
then I thought to learn the basics
but once you have the basics what you
really need to focus on is repetition
repetition and getting better and just
doing a lot so things will take time but
to get the basics and get up to speed it
doesn't necessarily have to takes a long
time but just manage your expectations
and that learning the code it's not
something to do on a whim and you need
to be ready to commit maybe you know
several months a half a year a year
depending on what you want to get out of
programming if you want to learn to code
definitely think longer than two weeks
in learning to code you can also get
trapped into spending too much time on
stuff that might you might realize
afterwards weren't giving you as much I
want as beneficial to you so you should
instead of forcing yourself to stick
with the course you found you should
rather try and try different courses
different books different different
learning formats and see what works for
you and what some of the combinations of
resources and courses and curriculum and
teachers etc might speed up things for
you so don't be afraid to experiment
again realistic time frame we already
talked about and it helps to form
helpful habits so instead of sitting
down and forcing yourself to learn for
two hours if you have habits in place
and routines where it's not an issue
it's not a struggle to get started it
makes it easier it's not easy to form
habits it takes commitment in the
beginning but once it's habits it makes
it it's a habit it's much easier just to
get going daft
is one thing that you can be faced with
I think especially when you're thinking
about applying for jobs even when you've
got your first job or when you've
started study like I had a wall after
like three four months of starting if we
go camp I was like god dammit can I
really do this there's so much left to
learn
I loved eating success stories for
breakfast I still do there's tons of
success stories on free code camp the
medium publication if you just google it
online there's so much stuff out there
just talk to
people in the audience today and just
remember that everyone started somewhere
so even the most you know accomplished
developer out there or even the most
accomplished speaker such less persona
and whatever pick your programming
language stage started somewhere some
people yes started when they were almost
starting to walk in us like four or five
year olds but most people started later
in life and there's tons of success
stories of people starting when they
were twenty thirty forty fifty there was
recently a great article by Quincy
Larson the founder of free curve camp on
just that topic even for experienced
developers Google is your best friend so
if you're doubting how to do this
someone else probably have also asked
the same question can I really do what I
was tasked to do right now or what I
chose to create so don't be afraid to
Google all the time
the only still to the haters it depends
a bit about on your family and your
friends I've been blessed to not have so
many people questioning why I was
learning to code or what what's why have
you learning to code and stuff like this
but I know some people have that issue
and it's not easy to just ignore them if
they're important part of your life but
don't give them too much their opinions
too much value and yes you can we have
again success stories tons of stories
here today of people that have dealt
with doubt and still have overcome and
managed to learn to code resources
mentioning this it ties into some of the
other things we've discussed when you
are faced with doubt or time constraints
also in the beginning but when you are
hitting a wall and feeling like Oh free
code camp this may be not for me or
you're doing another online course or
you're reading a book and you're getting
stuck don't be afraid to question the
resource that you are using to learn to
code I supplemented free code camp first
with eloquent JavaScript a book and then
gradually more with udemy video courses
but just don't be afraid to experiment
this tons of free resources there's tons
of cheap course
so the main focus on how to deal with
resources is don't be afraid to test out
things and switch it up but on the other
flipside don't get too fragmented like
there's the shiny object syndrome of
course you might try to buy every new
fancy course and think that that's going
to be in the blue tail that's gonna get
you from A to B in two weeks doesn't
work like that
but find something I work for you and
when you find something stick with it I
can also help to have a mentor it's not
always so easy to find an absence of
that Co students can be in my experience
really good to just meet regularly at
meetups taking initiative to meet people
for coffee and some talking about code
to you know give each other feedback and
to have this social sort of pressure to
when you meet someone the next time oh I
should have completed that JavaScript
calculator let me just do that before I
meet them tomorrow and their programming
is worth trying if you haven't there's a
lot of online communities where you can
meet people and pair program for for a
session you can also meet people in real
life pair programming is sitting
together with someone else and coding on
the same thing on one screen normally
just to not bore you too much I took in
a bonus point here an obstacle we're
learning to code can be vim if you don't
know a whim is it's a code editor in the
terminal spin around since the beginning
of unix times or not so long but it's
been around for a couple of decades and
it's infamously infamous for being hard
to exit out of so if you just open it up
and you don't know how to exit out of it
you probably will not figure out and you
close your terminal but this is more of
a joke than a real obstacle if you want
to know how to exit them this is how you
access them just to have that included
so you literally just to escape to have
the command section and then you have :
q an exclamation mark but you might be
normally fine without the exclamation
mark it sounds simple but on the other
hand it sounds may be unnecessary when
you just gonna exit something so let's
get back on track distractions it's
another thing as with anything in life
especially with the infamous Millennials
and all the distractions we have these
days it's easy to sit down and you were
going to learn to code today and then
two hours later you've been checking
everything on YouTube and all the latest
JavaScript news or whatever it's a bit
tricky one because again for me what
helps the most is I realized the one
thing I haven't put here I'll mention
that but its habits again if you manage
to do stuff for the right reasons and
also form the habits that you need to
have the routine that works for you like
every Friday like every morning for 20
minutes at lunch or in the evening
before you watch your favorite TV series
or whatever that you just stick with
some routines and routines and follow
them I like really the routine of just
sticking with free code camp and getting
the points and getting the brownie
points if I help people at free core cam
torgue via the chat room you get brownie
points with people thank you I'm just
kind of kept like wanting that
statistics of my points to go up that
was the motivating force one thing I
didn't put up here is that it helps to
know I got distracted so I forgot what
it was so we'll get back to that and
then again to the better resources I
think that's the theme of this talk now
but if you get distracted it might be
because the course is not the best fit
for you maybe you would do better
reading a book for an hour than for
following something video or maybe
tutorials we get to do stuff as you go
along is better for you and so on
and also one thing yeah that's actually
it is here but just didn't realize the
thing that I forgot is work on your Y so
if you feel black
motivation or being distracted too
easily it might be because you're
lacking motivation we need to learn to
code you might rethink why you're
learning to code and if it's really the
right thing for you now maybe it's a
better fit in a year to be honest
something happened you're like oh no I
need to do this for other reasons but if
you don't either have the passion for
programming code these kind of things or
you have the right reason to do it it
will be harder it's just a fact so you
can still do it you just need to figure
out how to work on that for you I've
been blessed that I've been loving
computer since I could walk and tap on
keyboards I just didn't get into
programming until the last yeah recently
well both will say the questions were
after because we are filming so it's not
so easy to take the questions during the
filming but just keep them if you had
some getting stuck again we've covered
this sort of and we've covered switching
up one thing I want to focus on is that
if you feel like you're you were
committing to a course or a material and
you're like yeah but I can't give up I'm
so invested in this for whatever reason
it's fine you can just stop try
something else
and it might work you might even return
to where you were because you learned
something from a different perspective I
had that experience with eloquent
JavaScript reading that for several
chapters and I got the same things that
I were explained in free code camp
curriculum in a different way and it was
like aha now I felt more equipped to
tackle the course afterwards debugging
is a thing where it depends on what
you're coding in it depends a bit on you
and how strict you are on debugging
with debugging tools in the beginning or
not there are different opinions on this
but whichever way you are debugging with
your language with your tool set of
tools
it helps getting better at figuring out
why your code is not working right now
Google again as we talked about if
you're doing front-end the chrome
developer tools and getting better at
breakpoints and
debugging having debugger as a as
variable name or like a method that you
hook into your JavaScript and it stops
in the browser to give you the to stop
in time where you are debugging and
those kind of things help if you don't
know much about this and I've had
problems coding look into debugging just
google it what helps for me sometimes
and there's been done studies on this if
you are coding and you feel stuck and
this could be professionally or learning
to code it might be good with the
context switch where you just force
yourself to be like but I mean in the
middle of this I can make this work and
then you're an hour later I can make
this work and you're like okay stop just
take a break 10 to 15 minutes go for
work do something entirely different and
you might be like but now and then you
go back to it or just the fact that you
had a break you go back and you look at
it for fresh eyes very often helps yeah
Google again okay so for one of the last
points I think it's the last obstacle
we're going over today is deflation you
might be like Oh goddamn it I've I've
been trying to learn to code for like
one week three months half a year or
more and you feel like yeah you need
some motivation you're like maybe it's
not for me or whatever in my experience
it helps to go to meetups or to
socialize with others again about that
also are learning to code sometimes it
might have to be proactive for me and
also no Donny Danielle it helps to look
at motivational talks documentaries I
love these kind of success stories again
or seeing like how this you know seven
year old kid that was a programming
prodigy got into college early and just
conquer the world with his iOS apps and
those kind of things and I'm like if he
can do that I can certainly get further
in my course material and stuff like
this
yeah and ultimately your why so if
you're if you're kind of stuck ask
yourself why am I doing this and maybe I
try to do some self motivation
cool just to make this talk even more
exciting we're hiring at my company I
mentioned this before but we're still
hiring a front-end or slash full stack
developer we're also looking for a
back-end the profile for both is a bit a
little bit more experienced because yeah
that's the general gist
have a look or send us an email if you
are interested in if you feel you don't
have enough experience
feel free to still approach me or send
an email or look at the website it might
still be worth a look for you yeah I
worked there I yeah do JavaScript
front-end stuff with VJ s mainly at the
moment cool I think yes I think that was
it
before we end I want to reinforce and
I'll follow this up with putting a repo
in the comment sessions because I want
this talk to be something that people
can contribute to I realized giving this
talk that there's a lot of
repetitiveness and there's some stuff
that I could maybe when I talking about
it could want to add myself if people
have stuff they would like to add or
feel they can contribute with help on
how to overcome obstacles you're free to
help with this talk for the future thank
you very much
[Applause]